Imagine you get sent, day in and day out,
to a random company to work without pay.
Each workday starts with an hour-long meeting
followed by another meeting, and another meeting
and so on and so forth.
All meetings are on different, seemingly random
corporate objectives: focus on x, improve
y, remember z.
Your primary job: sit down, shut up, listen
to your supervisor and take note.
And when you think that the day is finally
over, you are told to take some of the work
home.
Sounds like a horrific corporation doesn’t
it?
This, however, is the perceived reality of
many young people in what's called a twenty-first
century school.
So how did we happen to end up here?
Frederick the Great, the King of Prussia,
came up with the idea of modern factory schools.
The emperor was inspired by Plato who argued
that the ideal city requires ideal individuals,
and ideal individuals require an ideal education.
And so the King introduced compulsory education
in 1763 with the mission to unify Germany,
increase literacy, and boost the education
of all its citizens - including the very poor.
The early Prussian school system provided
eight-years of instruction in reading, writing,
music and religious studies.
It imposed a strict ethos of duty, discipline
and obedience.
And that worked.
The model turned into a big cultural, economical
and military success that inspired rulers
from Tokyo to Washington.
Not long after, state officials all around
the world started writing curriculums, and
public education became both: a child’s
right and duty.
In 1938 the Germans then went one step further
and made school attendance compulsory.
Ever since it’s not parents, but the state
that makes sure kids go to school.
Today 85% out of all adults worldwide are
literate and access to information is abundant.
Should government officials still have a monopoly
on how we learn?
A growing number of parents don’t think
so and want to take control over their own
child’s education.
They advocate for what’s called unschooling.
Unschooling is the process of learning through
life, outside institutionalized classrooms.
Similar to homeschooling it usually happens
at home or in other places.
But while homeschooling usually follows a
formal curriculum, unschooling doesn’t.
Unschoolers learn through their natural life
experiences including play, chores, travel,
books, elective classes, board-games, internships,
mentors, and living in a community.
Parents or tutors play a big role.
They provide resources, facilitate the learning
experiences, and help the child to reflect
on their progress.
So how come parents choose to unschool their
children when it’s much more convenient
to send them to school?
There are 6 key reasons.
Schools can negatively affect the parent-child
relationship, often replacing
it with an atmosphere
of fear.
Institutionalizing kids in a one-size-fits
all classroom is an inefficient use of their
time and potential, because it requires each
one to learn a subject in a particular way,
and at a pace that doesn’t take into account
a child's interests or any pre-existing knowledge
they might have.
In school, children are primarily taught how
to follow instructions, which means they don’t
practice doing things independently.
Unschoolers have to solve problems by themselves
all the time.
They learn to work autonomously.
School children are told all their lives what
to do.
As a result they later often have no idea
what they want and hence simply conform.
Unschoolers practice making their own decisions
every day.
They learn to know what they want and are
more likely to question social ills.
School focuses almost exclusively on what
to learn all day.
Unschoolers learn to ask the much more important
question: why learn it?
Schools cover only a few subjects someone
thought of a few hundred years ago.
Unschoolers can explore way more interests,
and look into topics at far greater depth.
John Holt, a pioneer of unschooling, said
it as follows: "The anxiety children feel
at constantly being tested, their fear of
failure, punishment, and disgrace, severely
reduces their ability both to perceive and
to remember, and drives them away from the
material being studied into strategies for
fooling teachers into thinking they know what
they really don't know.
What do you think?
What are the good and bad sides of unschooling?
And more broadly, should the state or parents
decide what to teach a child and what to leave
out.
Who should have the ultimate say?
Please share your thoughts in
the comments below!
If you like how we explain complicated
ideas in simple cartoon animation,
you can support us! Visit
patreon.com/sprouts! Just visit us,
learn how it works and what’s in it
for you. We hope to see you there.
And if you are a parent or educator, check
out our website sproutsschools.com. There
you can find this and other video lessons,
additional resources and classroom activities.
If you found this helpful, check
out our other videos and subscribe.
If you want to support our work,
join us on patreon.com/sprouts.
For more information and additional
contents, visit sproutsschools.com